well hello hello everybody and welcome
welcome welcome we're so excited to have
so many of you on with us first thing in
the morning
um for those of us in the pacific time
zone hope you are all having a fantastic
day so far
you have joined us with askdoc live
my name is rebecca kozak and i will be
your host for the next two hours as we
provide some amazing information that is
life transforming and empowering
without having to
you know ask for permission
remember you are an individual with an
intelligent mind and
when you have the information
that your body needs to make intelligent
decisions
life is so much easier
so much easier but today we will be
joined with a co-host jonty mccollier
and nasima omar for those of you who are
on live with us
you can raise your hand choose from the
zoom menu raise your hand and you can
ask dr wallach questions here live with
us so we encourage you to raise your
hand early because i will be going in
the order that the hands are received
or raised rather
and i'll also be working on some emails
and some text messages that i've
received through facebook messenger and
we just want to make sure that everybody
is getting information that is going to
be again useful and empowering
and making sure that you
have
the nutritional information you need to
live an optimal life
now
this program
and the contents of this program is to
provide educational information only on
the importance of nutrition and
supplementation in a world where the
food supply is empty and void of what
the body needs most
not just to survive but thrive
in this program we will be sharing the
nutritional options that are available
through supplementation in a form that
the body can readily absorb and utilize
the fdia does require us to let you know
that our products are not meant to treat
prevent diagnose or cure any diseases
and this program is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
but
you know we bring a message of hope the
genetic theory and the things that have
happened within your family history do
not have to define who you are
with epi
genetics which is the study of how your
behaviors and environment can cause
changes
and affect the way that your genes work
is so
so encouraging i know it was for me
and with the epigenetics you are an
empowered individual and have more
control over your health journey than
you think
this program is brought to you by
askdoclive.com
and for those of you who
have never spoken to anybody about any
of the supplementation that will be
spoken about today feel free to go to
our website askdoclive.com
we have a contact us there where if you
don't know exactly what you need
you can click the contact us and get an
email to us and one of our certified
holistic health coaches will get back
with you to make sure that you're
getting exactly what you need
we also have a
store there if you'd like to go shopping
by yourself but again this is for
somebody that has never made a purchase
or has never spoken to anybody and was
not referred to this program by anybody
specific
i want it to be very clear that if one
of your friends
shared this program with you
get back with them they have a vested
interest in making sure that that you
are
getting the information and they are a
resource to you where we want to be a
resource as well the person that shared
this program with you
is also a resource and they probably
have their own special way of getting
products
so with that being said
we are honored to have one of the
founding fathers of epigenetics here to
share the best options
to obtain or maintain optimal health
dr joe wallick thank you so
very much
for taking two hours out of your busy
schedule
every friday with us we just appreciate
you love you
and
yeah i don't know how to say thank you
enough
well it's very kind rebecca and thank
you so much and i consider the astock
live family family and so
it's always good to be with you in touch
spaces and have a family to go to every
friday morning so thank you so much
um you guys do a great job in helping so
many people i'm just
amazed and so proud
well we still have to talk a little bit
about the
covid thing because it's spiking again
and the reason why it spikes is people
don't pay attention to details things
begin to look good and they just throw
everything to the wind and go back to
the old ways and they step on the land
mine again
and that's why we have all the spiking
um
as of this morning still uh there's
still last night's figures uh we have 46
million 174 517 infections in the united
states and 753
dead now to put that in perspective
that's the 18 month accumulation of
deaths from the code 753
7747 dead
you look at two years in 1918 and 1919
during the spanish flu in america alone
we lost 675 000 people see subtracted
675 000 from our 753 000
and you get 78 070 747
more in 18 more deaths in 18 months than
they had in two years
it's not a very good record because you
know it's quite a bit
a time has lapsed
we've had between then
we've had h1n1 we have mers and sars and
the swine flu
and
we've had coveted two
and so forth and i guarantee you we're
gonna have another
pandemic in plague uh when this one is
over it might be three months it might
be six months it might be a year might
be two years but it's coming
and that's because people
aren't changing fast enough and hard
enough and completely enough
what needs to be changed is our basic
basic behavior
and
doctors have given us a lot of
misinformation for many years that's why
i wrote the book epigenetics so that
everybody
uh can you know they can go to you and
get that book
and ask live correct
yes okay we have all of your popular
publications right there on the website
okay very good and so that book will
really
shake you up
because there are no january transmitter
diseases there are no autoimmune
diseases doctors just made that up when
they didn't know what the answers were
and they were too embarrassed to say we
don't know so they blamed it on you oh
it's your genes making that happen oh
it's it's uh you're your body's
attacking itself you have an autoimmune
disease like lupus and stuff like that
it's absolutely not true
so you're empowered to know that you can
defend yourself against all these things
but you have to be proactive you have
you can't just sit there and whistle in
the wind you got to do something
and two things are very important
um number one all preexisting conditions
like diabetes and hybrid pressure and
arthritis and peripheral neuropathies
and lupus and parkinson's disease and
varicose veins and gray hair and all
these things are
really just early warning signals
something bad is going to happen to you
okay these are all nutritional
deficiencies none of our autoimmune none
of them are genetic
that was all false information
and the breakdowns started
three o'clock in the afternoon monday
september 4th 1882
on pearl street in new york city and the
bluff overlooking the stretch of the
brooklyn bridge when thomas edison and
jonathan leaves pulled the switch on the
first commercial electric generating
plant
and
they let loose electricity well within
20 years we had 40 new diseases never
nobody's ever seen before and doctors
blamed it on genetics and autoimmune
because they didn't know what it was so
they just blamed it on you
and
um as a result
uh we're in real trouble well the reason
why that happened was when we went to
electricity we gave up
all the years of getting minerals by
putting wood ashes which are 98
minerals and only two percent carbon uh
into our gardens and the vegetables
would suck up the minerals we'd eat the
vegetables get minerals that way and
grandma would always put minerals some
of you are old enough to remember
grandma putting the wood ashes into our
food
and certainly her food and that's why
grandma lived to be 110
and then everybody else in her family
following her only lived in their 60s
and 70s gave up 40 30 40 50 years
well we got the same jeans grandma had
yeah but she was using wood ashes in her
food and wood ashes in the garden you're
not doing that anymore because you got
electricity
that's the bad part
well uh these pre-existing conditions
again
when you look at somebody like colin
powell
one of one of the greatest politicians
we've had
in american history in modern history
um you know he was a soldier in our army
he became a four-star general uh he was
the first uh black person to become the
joint chairman of joint chiefs of staff
he was the first black person to become
the secretary of state for the united
states
and he just died you know about a week
ago
at um age 84 which beats our average at
7 which is 75. he beat it by nine years
but you knew he was in trouble when you
go back and look at his pictures i went
back and looked at his pictures from 30
40 years ago and he had snow white hair
back then which is one of those early
warning signals because snow white hair
has nothing to age people say well you
gotta expect that i'm 70 years old no
babies are born with snow white here
okay it's a nutritional deficiency and
the nutritional deficiency that causes
gray and silver and white hair the same
nutritional deficiencies that cause
varicose veins spider veins hemorrhoids
aneurysms in the brain aneurysm of the
aorta coronary arteries
and so these are warning signals you
need to pay attention to
and so he
i can tell you just from his gray hair
that he
um
was actually eating gluten probably
oatmeal for breakfast and that kind of
stuff typical military breakfast
pancakes and waffles and maybe even
drinking beer nothing wrong with
drinking beer but if you're gonna drink
beer drink the rice beer don't drink the
wheat beer okay
and then
um
uh he he
also his skin was a lot lighter as he
got older because he couldn't make the
skin pigment like he had when he was a
young man
okay
and so this is were the giveaways that
he was was eating gluten not absorbing
he may have been taking a vitamin you
know maybe taking one a day with 27
nutrients in so he was only 63 short
okay
and so this is this is the thing you
have to deal with and when you have
these pre-existing conditions
number one your intestines die so over a
period of time slowly slowly slowly not
just overnight but maybe over a period
of 5 10 15 20 years
so your efficiency of absorption and
nutrients is way down
you may only absorbing 2 percent instead
of even 50 percent
and then
also
uh when you have an absorption problem
uh he was probably again not taking
enough supplementation
and so this is what caught up with him
and his immune system and his bone
marrow wasn't working
properly
and so the the virus got him it killed
him
at age 84 which is not bad but it's not
perfect and
i'm sure he had these other issues
and when they did his obituaries they
didn't say oh he had this disease this
disease and this disease this disease
they didn't list all that because his
medical history you know he's dead is
his personal
business
um
another thing
we want to talk about
is um it's never too late because you
can heal your intestines by giving up
meat butter i know so you can see a big
difference within two to four weeks and
so i want everybody to give up we'd
brought around oats we'll just start
eating like an asian eat rice and sweet
potatoes and and beans and squash and
corn you can eat corn you can't have
fried corn you can have roasted corn on
the cob or you know you can boil uh i i
like to cut the
kernels off the cob and and simmer them
and
and boil them in water and then put
butter on them
um but you cannot fry corn
okay
you know
that's bad no fried foods
and you switch over to an asian diet now
give an example
my favorite example is india
india has 1.3 billion people they're the
second largest population in the world
we take india and china together they
make up one-third of the world's
population just those two countries
alone
so india is very highly populated but
like china it is
a very homogeneous country we have
probably people from
50 to 100 different countries here in
the united states
so we're
you know we have everything you can
think of well in china they're almost
all chinese and india they're almost all
people from you know who are indians
and so
um
basically they have 29 states and seven
territories
the northern nine states have
ninety-five percent of the deaths from
coven and eighty-seven percent of the
infections
the
twenty southern states and two
territories
have only five percent of the deaths and
only 17 percent of the infections but
they're homogeneous people why's they're
different well for a hundred years the
british occupied northern india to draft
all their young men to send out to do
their fighting for them so they wouldn't
have to draft english young men
and they taught the northern united
states how to grow wheat growing around
oats how to make beer from wheat brought
around oats how to eat oatmeal for
breakfast how to make pancakes how to
make white flour
all that kind of stuff and how to grow
it and sell wheat run around oats
and so northern india just lives on
wheat bran around oats in southern india
20 states and seven territories live
like asians they live on rice and corn
and beans and squash and seaweed
and so that's what makes up the
difference
and so this is very telling stuff and i
just hope people take you know
heat of that
now i also want you as kind of
preventive
to take our colloidal silver
um this is in addition well i i've
skipped something there you need to take
the 90s engine nutrients and right now
you need the heavy hammer the healthy
brain and heart pack
one per hundred pounds of body weight
for kids we have the kids toddy which is
a liquid and it tastes good they like it
um it has everything in it except for
the efas so you have to have an extra
bottle of bfa's for them if they don't
want to either chew or swallow the soft
gel capsules they can
uh puncture them with a needle and
squirt it into their kids toddy they can
have the kids tied with the efas in it
from the moment they're born if the
mama's going to feed them
milk replacers like infamil and similac
if the mother's going to breastfeed the
baby she needs to have double her
healthy brain and heart pack because
she's giving nutrients to the baby as
well as herself
and if everybody were to take the 90
essential nutrients and stay away from
gluten for at least a year before they
get pregnant we'd never have another
birth defect 99.9 of birth defects
are caused
by nutritional deficiencies and most
women don't take prenatal vitamins and
shame on the ob gyns even though they're
in the childbearing years they don't
take prenatal vitamins until they miss
one or two periods and the baby is
almost nearly farmed already by the time
they start taking prenatal vitamins and
that's why there's so many birth defects
shame on the ob gyns
well
i want everybody else to get our bottles
of colloidal silver our colloidal silver
of course comes in four ounce bottles i
i go through two of these bottles a
month uh i've been doing for 25 years
you put two droppers full under your
tongue 30 minutes for each meal and two
drivers full on your tongue two and four
bedtime
and the colloidal silver it's like water
it's clear doesn't have any taste
whatsoever even little babies will take
it and smile at you because they think
it's funny because you're squirting
water in their mouth that's really cold
silver
and it kills viruses bacteria fungus and
yeast then our hand sanitizer okay the
hand side of towers i go through about
eight or ten of these little two ounce
bottles a month
i i use it for
there's no alcohol so it doesn't burn so
i use it for after shave i use it on my
hands between my toes i use it on my
arms up to my shoulders i use my legs up
to my knees
because i go out and and i don't want to
pink pick up and bring home anything
that has any covet
okay
and then
uh you also want to add to the healthy
branded heart pack the killer biotic
which is
it's got like six different species of
mushrooms and the primary useful one i
like is the reishi mushroom it actually
supports your immune system as
anti-inflammatory and release pain
and the
cell shield rtq is another one which
supports your immune system and relieves
uh infirmary inflammation
and then oxy body or oxygen
um it's a liquid it tastes good little
kids like it and i take an ounce of our
oxy body at breakfast now oxy body at
dinner time
because i want more oxygen
and this brings us to one of the topics
of the day that rebecca wanted to talk
about
okay and this is of course
um sleep apnea sleep issues can't sleep
well you wake up your
what's your sort of crabby because you
didn't sleep well and so forth
um and so i want everybody to start a
victory garden
in addition to doing all the supplements
we talked about and staying away from
all the bad stuff the gluten the wheat
the barley right notes sugar carbonated
drinks
fried foods all that's got to go
but also in addition
to that
and all the colloidal silver and the
hand sanitizer and the kids tidy and
efas for the kids
don't forget the rebound instead of soft
drinks uh it has a hundred nutrients in
it it's not like red bull it has
caffeine and sugar in it okay we ours
has a hundred nutrients and it's 75
minerals and 25 vitamins amino acids
and then i want you to have a victory
guard in every house i want you to have
plants and no flowers on them because we
don't want you know well i was allergic
to the pollen i don't want to hear any
of that so just green plants
and i want them in every room that has
windows like your kitchen your bathroom
your bedroom the playroom for the kids
the living room
and put a couple of potted plants
in each one of those rooms right near
the windows and get some sunshine
and and then of course i want you to
take
two ounces of liquid plant-derived
colloidal metals and put those two
ounces of those minerals in
a pint of water and water each of those
plants for that pint of water each week
and those plants
while you're sleeping is going to be
doing photosynthesis and and
breaking down carbon dioxide in the air
in the house
to oxygen
and carbon chains for for its own use
now think about it a sequoia tree that
weighs 30 tons all that wood came from
the carbon dioxide in the air that's
where that wood came from
where'd that wood come from it was from
the green leaves
those little baby trees started making
wood and as that tree grew is more and
more wood it came from the from the
carbon dioxide in the air but then of
course those trees put out a lot of
oxygen as a result
when you don't have enough oxygen you're
not going to sleep well you're going to
be crabby when you wake up
and you're not going to be able to you
know remember things and you'll be
confused
and it's going to be a mess
and you'll be depressed and you go to
the doctor they put you on drugs well
you do this
victory garden thing with the
plant-derived minerals in your plants
with the water because you know tap
water doesn't have anything in it
and what they forget to tell you in
school whether in medical school or
kindergarten
both about the same
the
the thing they failed to tell you is
when a green plant is in the sun and
it's a green planet so it has
chlorophyll
uh which is a chlorophyll in the
mitochondria the little things in your
cells that make energy and it's called
they turned into what's called
chloroplast
but the chloroplast cannot do
photosynthesis without 20 nutrients
there's 20 nutrients required for the
series about chemical reactions that
allow the plant to break down carbon
dioxide into carbon chains
and oxygen if that plant is not getting
those 20 nutrients as they say in france
there ain't nothing happening okay and
this is our big problem everybody thinks
it's just sunshine and green plants no
it's those 20 nutrients that are
necessary for the green plants and the
chlorophyll in the chloroplast to do
photosynthesis
and this is what killed
all the trilobites they had 25 000
species of trilobites for millions and
millions of years before the dinosaurs
even came along
and then
they all died and you know they had five
mass extinctions and so those all those
thousands and thousands of species of
aquatic
organisms
uh died
and then
all the dinosaurs died over a hundred
thousand years because they didn't have
any oxygen
uh as well
and
we have all these dead zones
where there's you know
in our own gulf of mexico
we have six thousand three hundred
square miles of dead zone we have a new
dead zone here in america that's in the
delta of the columbia river the west
coast of oregon because we blocked up
all the minerals going to the
coast
coastal algae in oregon
and so then all the reefs are dying for
the same reason all the dead zones are
done and so i spent a lot of time
looking at what were the common threads
and came up with a cd called dr
wallach's laws a photosynthetic
you can see here photosynthetic
disruption and global warming global
warming has nothing to do with all these
die outs and
okay pollution has nothing to do with
all these diodes there were no cars
millions of years ago when there were
trilobites and dinosaurs
it's why they die
in every case there is
a series of glaciers glaciers glaciers
glacier glaciers whether it's
100 and 400 million years ago
with the trilobites
um 250 million years ago with the
dinosaurs
uh currently with the dead zones
now the biggest dead zone is the arabian
sea which is to india as the gulf of
mexico is the
united states
and i asked siri siri
uh are there any glaciers
uh in india
yes there's ten thousand what
so i asked again from a different
direction
are there any glacier moraines and
glaciers in india there's ten thousand
glaciers and each one has an average of
two to four marines
i forgot about the himalayan mountains
all those glaciers in the himalayan
mountains and the glaciers and the
marines the little dams they push in
front of them some of them are 500 foot
tall and 25 miles wide and they block
100 or sometimes they just redirect the
flow of surface water and the minerals
to the green leafy plants that are
producing the oxygen so the mass
die-offs did not occur from global
warming they didn't occur from pollution
and of course the same thing is going on
with the
um reefs
it's going on because of dams
okay the dams from glaciers
before humans came along
okay uh
millions of years ago in the trilobites
and those other organisms
uh when all the dinosaurs died out the
dead zones
and the dead zone in the arabian sea
from india is 66 000
66 000 square miles
of dead zone in the arabian sea because
of a mixture of human dams and also 10
000 glaciers
and then of course the reefs are dying
for the same reason when you look at the
great barrier reef which is 1 400 miles
long on the east coast
of
queensland and australia
guess what
um
there's 183
183 dams damming up the flow of
nutrients to the great barrier reef and
that's why the
central 50 percent of the great barrier
reef is in trouble the northern 25
percent that's not happening so it's
happy the southern 25 percent is not
happening so they're happy it's only the
central area where they have 183 dams
for hydroelectric irrigation water
storage
let's see here also for flood control
and they've cut off the food supply
to the algae in the great barrier reef
that produces the oxygen
for the polyps
okay for the coral polyps that make and
maintain the reef so without the oxygen
the coral polyps can't do their job
and without the minerals the algae in
the reefs can't do their job
and so
this is all very simple and it's on this
cd which is available now you can get
this seed it's dr wallach's laws of
photosynthetic disruption and global
warming so we've only got a few minutes
left in this segment so i'm going to
turn it back over to to you rebecca
all right dr wallach
and i just want people to realize that
you know
this the whole damn thing started before
humans started making their dance
right doctor
so these two 2 billion years 2 billion
years before we came along
so the natural formation where things
just like get stuck and start building
up and just limit
that flow of minerals
that are going to where
the geography of the land
actually needs them
so
i it's it is kind of good news that it's
not just all
human
you know we know how to deal with it and
so yeah we know how to deal with it so
all these dams we're putting up we can
still we're not going to give up our
electricity so what we do
is we
have all this silt from behind the dams
right here in america each year we get
150 million tons
150 million tons rebecca each year
behind our hydroelectric dams in america
and we sell it to local farmers as
fertilizers so it never makes it to the
gulf of mexico that's why the gulf of
mexico is dying
that's that's that's a lot i mean i know
what
60 tons look like because that's what's
needed for rock on my driveway but
that's a lot
yeah 150 million tons every year is a
lot
yeah
and
and like you said i mean you take that
it's built building up it's got to be
used for something
hold it back into the soils where our
food is growing
because plants can't make minerals right
dr wallach that's correct plants can
make vitamins but they cannot make
minerals it has to be in the soil for
them to take it up and have it in the
food that they provide to us
i'll give you an a plus
well and not all farmers
realize this or have the funds
to to put those minerals back into the
ground
you know i i'm surrounded by farmers i
love farmers
i
mean i can
i can only see two neighbors and they
both farm
so
the fact that they are doing so much to
help provide food
we just have to realize that
what's
the food that's being provided even if
it's organic
i mean organic just means you're not
getting as many chemicals and pesticides
and herbicides that's right it says
nothing about the
says nothing about the nutritional value
of the food organic doesn't say anything
about nutritional value
exactly does not mean that it's more
nutritious
it's just less toxic
but we need nutrition
and that's where
your decades of research dr wallach in
figuring out okay
we've got all of this disease
what was missing
and you figured it out
not only in the animal world but then
you applied it to the
human world
and there was correlations
and you took it upon yourself to you
know step out of that
role as a veterinarian and pathologist
into having to deal with people that
talk back
yeah i i love live people
yeah making such a difference in in
providing the nutritional information
that is needed to help
us
to help us at the cellular level and out
and
i i just
me i i
i have you in my prayers dr wallach and
i praise god for you well i i appreciate
that believe i appreciate that god is my
favorite hero
and of course i have a new book coming
out it may be three four months before
it's out
but um it's gonna be called the third
testament
okay because it goes into all these
things because god is the wisest one of
us all he is the architect he is
everything
and no matter what faith or religion you
have it always comes up to the good lord
right
and
uh it's one of those things where
uh you cannot deny that we're dinosaurs
you cannot deny their trilobites you
know these things are all in fossils and
they have the equipment to date them and
we have telescopes we can see so far out
in space that they had no imagination
what it was i mean remember
that the
old testament and the new testament were
written by human beings and they didn't
have all this
information available to them so they
wrote with what they knew what they
could see and what they were told and so
on
and so
this book that i'm writing i'm calling
it the third testament
not because i think i'm anything special
but because i'm taking all this
information that are missing from those
books because even dinosaurs were god's
creations
even trilobites were god's creations and
so we have to include them in the
picture
and so that's what i've done i've gone
back to the beginning of time
genesis 1 1.
in in the beginning god created the
heavens and the earth but it didn't say
whether it was five minutes or five
years or fifty years or five thousand
years or five million years or five
billion years it doesn't say that it
just said god created everything which
is true and so i'm putting everything in
in timeline prescribed the perspective
it's been 2 000 years since the new
testament was written
so it's time
you know for
which i say
another um
add-on another edition
and so i'm very excited about this
well in in and it's going through and
just just claiming
the miracles and the works that are
going on that's right
it's just all every page
um
supports
the wisdom of the good lord
and it's just saying and here's the
things that he did and here's the reason
why we believe he did them and so forth
and and because you cannot deny
dinosaurs so
they weren't in anything in the old
testament or the new testament so
how could you take something that was
around for 250 million years before
human beings were and then there were
there were 12 different pre-humans that
walked upright and they were humans and
they used stone tools and they did
drawings and all kinds of stuff
on caves and you don't remember lucy
from australia or wherever she came from
it was a big exciting thing
and and so forth and so we have you know
either drawings or actual pictures like
from lucy
and these
individuals were created
millions of years before modern homo
sapiens came along you cannot deny they
were there we have the skeletons we have
the dating carbon dating and so forth on
them and so i had to include all them
with pictures or drawings of them based
on the skeletons and and so forth
and god everything god does is beautiful
he is the greatest architect he's the
greatest artist and sculptor of all and
so
this is all a very positive thing this
book is coming out it's just going to be
um everything's in praise of the good
lord but it completes
the picture i think
yeah absolutely i mean just driving
across
wherever you are in this world just
taking a road trip and looking around
and being observant of all that's going
on
i it's like
highway 89
going south from
the northern border to the southern
border and you've got the painted desert
and it's like
there's no way
no way it happened by accident
no
so
but dr walik i just appreciate all of
the work um and the thought that you put
into
just all of your work
all of your work and
it's keeping us
as a human being
well thank you
my my goal here and people say well why
do you do all this walk don't you ever
have a life
don't you play golf or anything i like
to fish because i can still think while
i'm fishing waiting for the fish to bite
um but the the whole idea here is to add
25 to 50 healthy years of people's lives
because you know in the bible it says
and god gave man 120 years well 75 isn't
very good
okay we're giving up
um
we're giving up 20 plus
uh 25
uh let's see that's 40 we're giving up
45 years
okay if 120 was correct but then we know
that if everything is right the human
life expectancy is 155. right now
we're leaving
uh let's see here right now we're
leaving um
let's see here we're leaving
oh my gosh we're leaving 80 years on the
table we're leaving 80 years on the
table
that's 80 years you could be spending
with people who you love spending time
with people you love you could 80 years
you could be doing the things you love
to do
why would you give that up just because
you don't want to
eat a certain way why would you give
that up because you don't want to avoid
certain bad things
um i'm going to avoid the bad things and
i'm going to eat what's right and take
all my supplements because i want to
live to be at least 110 be a super
centenarian i'm 83 now and most people
think i'm in my 50s when they look at me
they can't believe that i'm 83
and that's not even without you know
that's not even with the credit you know
we should be crediting people an extra
nine months because when you're born
you know they say okay well life begins
when the egg is fertilized by the sperm
okay if the life begins when an egg is
fertilized for the sperm then you're
nine months old when you're born
that's right or seven or ten you know or
eight yeah or what whatever
yeah
so uh
yeah we definitely
definitely need to um we have to correct
the math
we gotta yeah we gotta correct math and
yeah and the whole you know you looking
younger than you are and
i mean
when i tell people that i'm 50 they're
like no you're not you look like you're
25 dear i
and i am it i absolutely love it
uh well
everybody thank you so much for being on
ask doc live we appreciate you taking
the time out of your busy schedules to
empower yourself with knowledge that
will help you make wiser choices in the
foods that you eat and also
helping you to find the supplementation
that's actually going to work
synergistically in your bodies and give
results
so again if somebody referred you to
this program get back with them
if you were not referred to the program
we do have a store and also contact us
at askdoclive.com
and we are here to to assist you in
making sure that you're getting exactly
what you need
uh with our certified holistic health
coaches
now we have some hands up and again if
you're on with us and you want to ask dr
wallach questions here live
make sure you find the raised hand
option it might be under participants it
might be under
reactions just play around with whatever
zoom
version you have and find it and raise
your hand
so dr wallach let's first go with david
david go ahead and unmute yourself i did
good morning
good morning here i'm live with dr
wallach
yes good morning doctor
uh yes sir i have a question i have many
medical problems i'm diabetic
and i have high blood pressure but
recently my prolactin levels have gone
up very high and
i was wondering what can i do to lower
that without taking any pharmaceuticals
okay i got diabetes hybrid pressure and
you said something was how i didn't get
that
i'm sorry
you said some measurements were high
what was prolactin
oh
prolactin yes sir
okay
are you giving breast milk
no
okay
all right
um how much do you weigh in hello sir
i'm 62 and i weigh
190.
okay how tall are you
five nine
all right now do you have any other
issues do you have any skin problems
like eczema dermatitis or psoriasis
crisis
since i was a kid yes okay arthritis as
well yes okay do you have asthma also as
a kid i had it
okay
uh did you have your appendix out
yes
appendix out he had appendix operation
yes okay
and do you have any let's see
um
any bowel problems constipation diarrhea
irritable bowel syndrome diverticulitis
anything like that not really now
okay well you do
i'll tell you why in a moment are you
coloring your hair yes you have some
gray hair okay so you have hair problems
here
do you have any varicose veins there's
spider veins or hemorrhoids no
okay
uh let's see here
do you have any low back problems any
arthritis or joint problems yes
arthritis my hands i had numerous
surgeries
my
hands and fingers and knee operations
oh my gosh okay and then uh let's see
one last question
uh do you have any ring in your ears any
tinnitus ringing yours yes yes okay then
i gotta ask another question do you have
any afib or irregular heartbeat no
okay do you have any balance issues or
um dizziness some
vertigo okay yes all right
you have several things going on here
number one you have you have um a gluten
problem so your intestines are suffering
that's why you have all these
everything you have here's a nutritional
deficiency
and since you were a kid
and you were probably eating goat meal
for breakfast every morning and muffins
and pancakes and waffles and all the
good stuff right so you're getting you
were getting gluten poisoning as a kid
all the things you had as a kid and all
the things you have now including
psoriasis or nutritional deficiencies
caused particularly by gluten okay
and then same way you have osteoporosis
of the skull causing a squeezing of the
auditory branch of the eighth cranial
nerve causing the tinnitus ringing in
the ears you're getting a squeezing of
the vestibular branch of the ace cranial
nerve causing the vertigo
uh do you ever have bouts of hiccups
no
okay good all right well here we go
you need to get rid of all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no we brought a round
nose no sugar no carbon or drinks even
the diet one's got to go
once you replace any carbonated drinks
with a rebound or sports drink with a
hundred nutrients in it
um big guy like you 190 pounds you could
take two or three of those i only weigh
um 142 pounds i can drink two rebounds a
day
i don't drink them after three or four
o'clock because they'll keep you up all
night
okay
but that's to replace the soft drinks
and then i want you to take two healthy
brain and heart packs per month two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
the full dose everything twice a day
i want you to get uh also
uh
they contain the 215 nutrients
215 nutrients including the 90 essential
nutrients
that
are the basic core of what we talk about
and then i also want you to have two
bottles a month of our msm which takes
three at breakfast three at lunch street
dinner time take two bottles a month to
do that
and they're designed to support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
the bone itself now did you when you had
you said you had knee operations and so
forth did you when you had any joint
operations do they give you an
artificial knee or they just i have
artificial joints on my fingers on my
left hand yes okay
not in your knee but in your hands okay
um and so
um yeah also your skull is probably
squeezing your spinal cord is coming out
of the back your skull people don't
realize that your spinal cord forms in
the brain not in your back it's far your
spinal cord forms up here comes out the
back of the skull your skull is
squeezing it
and then you have
um
type 2 diabetes i want you to get two
bowels a month or sweeties you could
take three of those twice a day don't
cold turkey off your medication but as
your blood sugar comes down you can
slowly reduce your medication based on
the numbers okay
same thing with the high blood pressure
once you get two bottles a month over
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three twice a day and they will support
healthy blood pressure and healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries
do you have anything going on with your
kidneys or do your dialysis or anything
like that no i'm not completely okay
okay good all right so that's plenty for
you to to deal with uh i want you to
call us you know come on every two weeks
and give us a status report
your testimony is going to help millions
of people
david i believe you're an angel of god
and um you are going your testimony is
going to help millions of people because
all of these things you have are classic
nutritional deficiencies all secondary
to
the gluten thing if you're very very
good about getting rid of gluten
okay no wheat butter and oats you can
drink a beer but it can't be a beer made
from wheat it's got to be either
australia new zealand or some of these
we have some of the breweries here in
america make beer made from rice yes yes
okay and so
i have a glass of wine with dinner every
night a glass of red wine and so you
don't have to give that up i i have
gluten-free ice cream for dessert every
night a third of a pint i measured out
and cut the pine in half and everything
so i'm getting a third of a pint of
gluten-free ice cream
every night and i have like eight
different flavors so it's not boring
and so you can have you know good life
oh yeah you need three eggs twice a day
for your memory yeah
yes okay good but not fried and not hard
boiled they have to have soft yolks okay
okay okay
okay god bless you david you're going to
have a great great great testimony thank
you very much sir thank you god bless
you god bless you
thank you thank you all right thank you
david lots of great questions there and
great information dr wallach thank you
so much for for all that you share
and how thorough you are
i mean
i've been doing this for a little while
and you know it's one of those things
where
um
we're in 60 countries
and i see through your eyes
you know and through jonty's eyes and
through nasima's eyes and through
um
um ruth ellen's eyes yeah ruth ellen's
eyes i see
millions of people every day all over
the world that's why i did what i did
because i knew i had some things that
were going to help people and i didn't
want to just see 15 20 patients a day at
my little clinic in oregon
and so that's why i came out with um
dead doctors and lives in nine languages
now
we've sold over 600 million copies
on the cd in nine languages uh we just
had a guy in england
uh actually
um
by 1 000 books
okay
and i don't know what he's going to do
with him but he bought them
okay so that leverages my time into
england i don't have to go there and
give a lecture to 50 people because he's
taking those books to all those people
in england
right instead of 50 he's reaching a
thousand plus there you go that's
awesome
awesome awesome well dr wallach jill
writes in and she has a question she has
a client who is 64 years old female
weighs 156 pounds
she has an aortic valve problem that she
was born with two flaps instead of three
on her heart valve
her doctor is pressuring her to get
surgery
and
she's wanting to avoid it
but she gets out of breath when walking
up an incline
occasionally gets heart flutters as well
and the doctor says eventually surgery
to replace the heart valve because of
stenosis will be required
yeah
okay
and the doctor doesn't like that her
cholesterol is at 290
and that and she does admit that she
does eat out a lot
um well nothing wrong with that as long
as you choose correctly
exactly remember indiana jones when he
sees somebody who died he said he chose
poorly
right
so so she's uh jill says she got her
started on the healthy brain and heart
pack but what else
does she need
to deficiency
okay yeah she needs to get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no brown notes no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go
and she needs to in addition at 156
pounds with a heart problem i'd have her
take two healthy brain heart packs per
month the full dose everything twice a
day and also have her to get two bottles
a month for msm so you can take three
with each meal three breakfast lunch and
dinner
and
they will support and promote managed
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue including valves in
the heart which are made out of
connective tissue
okay
uh people don't realize that but the
valves in your heart are made out of the
same thing that tendons and ligaments
are made out of
all right
and then
i want her to
uh also
take the
um let's see here i wanted to take our
collagen okay she can take her glucogen
she can take
uh five of the capsules twice a day if
she wants to uh or she can take an ounce
twice a day of the liquid glucogen as
okay come in quartz would be two parts a
month but also i want her to have the
collagen peptides our collagen liquids
and our collagen liquids capsules okay
uh are made from beef cartilage and
ligaments and tendons
but our
um
um let's see here
our
collagen peptides are made from beef
sheep
poultry and fish
collagen
okay so you get a much broader
source of raw materials and so the
result is considerably faster
and more correct quickly and so jill
needs
um
the the two doses a day of the collagen
either the liquid or the capsules but i
also want her to to use two or three
scoops in the middle of the day of the
collagen peptides
and she could use whichever one she
wants but i'd go for the
the heavy duty ones
they have the four different animal
peptide collagen peptides in there
because
if her valves in her heart really
improve 10 15 because of the nutrition
that's going to them
she can just you know get another
opinion from another doctor from a
medical school something like that i
like a second opinions from medical
schools
because they get paid the same no matter
what the outcome or diagnosis is
whereas
if you're getting a second opinion from
the doctor's best friend who's his golf
buddy
uh
you understand what i'm saying here
they're kind of maybe scratching each
other's back
yeah they're
yeah they're going to milk you like a
dairy cow
well you got insurance it's not hurting
you the insurance pays
but then they kill you with the
procedure
yeah just like yeah just like when
people have afib
they'll anesthetize you cut your chest
open and then take a hot branding iron
and touch it to the heart to try and
stop it from doing your regular
heartbeats when we have afib it's
osteoporosis of the skull squeezing the
tenth cranial nerve the heart has
nothing to do with it and yet they cut
you anesthetize you cut you open and
kill your heart they kill so many
patients with that procedure it's called
ablation
it
obliterates the patient
well in so
the ablation within the heart and then
the burning of nerves for other issues
you know that's causing referred pain
for me
it just
does not make any sense
i mean god gave you all of those nerves
because it helps the body function
they're not the bad guys
the nerves are not bad guys and i i
heard this this week that
you're not sick
you're deficient
that's correct
and
and i think whenever we realize that
it's like okay i've got this going on
this going on this going on it's not
because i'm like sick well kind of the
sickness is caused by the deficiencies
yeah it's kind of like here's another
example
rebecca let's say he went to a new
mechanic and this guy's kind of a hippie
mechanic right he says look
don't use oil because you know this you
know we're talking about carbon fuels
and carbon things here don't use oil
just use dirt from texas or saudi arabia
or something like that
i use six quarts of dirt in your car
instead of six quarts of oil there's
bound to be some oil in it because dirt
from texas and saudi arabia an insane
person wouldn't do that to their car
when a doctor says look
you know you got all these problems and
so
um i want you to take this
pharmaceutical instead of food
oh
okay
yeah let's throw chemicals at it instead
of nutrition there you go oh my god
thank you
my doctor said i hear that so much
well i love what my doctor says and
folks you're hearing it right now
nutrition nutrition nutrition but it has
to be absorbable nutrition and you have
to
remove the things that are causing
digestive issues that are preventing the
body from being able to absorb what you
what you need yeah you get an a plus
rebecca
i was an a plus student in high school
so i'll i'll take control that was a few
years ago
well dr wallach let's go to the next
hand that is up and
sam
go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with doctor
okay bye
hey
yep am i am i unmuted yeah i am you're
unmuted buddy
once again i want to say thank you doc
and it's an honor to be uh on on your
army sir i mean
thank you yeah it's an onslaught that's
been going on for decades and uh
i have never felt more energy than in
the last six months since i have been on
the uh the 90 core nutrients and i've
been a high energy person for a long
time and uh
i i see it in baca i see it in everybody
it's real it's powerful
and uh i want to thank you for what
you're doing there's a lot of
unnecessary suffering going on today
okay okay
question i have in your cookbook it
talks about gluten-free
flour gf what exactly do they mean by
that they have to be using some other
type of grain or that's correct
okay what is it
rice
rice rice flour we were talking about
duh
there's no dumb question other than when
it's not answered
that's correct
[Laughter]
yeah okay you know there's there's
there's millet and there's there's corn
okay do you have any other questions
barb
ex i mean except question go ahead
quickly what's your question
come back don't put my face on all right
all right here's my question
i'm barbara bennett you gave me a long
list of things to take questions i had a
mini stroke there's like five things you
want me to take but i can't afford all
of it is there one or two that are more
important for my
brain health than anything else for my
tia
you know whatever it was okay
okay
well you're going to say you're going to
save a lot of money by getting rid of
the bad food you've got to get rid of
the bad bad foods are expensive no fried
foods no processed meats that's why
people have been asking me for rich
people been asking me for recipes for 20
years that's why i finally came out with
that book because you know doctor walks
cooking without the bad foods
uh so 300 pages for those of you haven't
seen it's a substantial book it's 300
pages okay and the print is small so you
get a lot of information okay
and then
um
how much you weigh
barb
oh sorry i it unmuted for the background
noise go ahead and unmute i mean
she weighs 186. 186.
okay and how tall is she
five seven and a half
okay five seven and a half i'd like to
see weigh 150 for a lady so it might be
30 40 pounds overweight
okay and so here we go um
that
if you can only take a couple of things
i would get a minimum of one healthy
brain and heart pack per month take at
least a half of those twice a day i
would also
get another bottle of our selenium
not from not from kroger's or
walgreens but from ours because it has
the five cofactors in it because i want
you to take six of our slime a day three
breakfast three at dinner time
and then the msm
um
take uh one bottle a month of that so
you can take six a day
uh if
if it's really necessary you can take
just three a day but
you do better faster if you do three
twice a day as the person promotes it's
gonna cost i know how much
okay so let's just go with that
but stay away from all
yeah diet diet diet
okay
sweet potatoes
thank you barbara thank you sam
all right
again lots lots of
lots of good questions and and dr well
like
you know
there's
and this is something that that i found
to be so true and you mentioned it when
you remove those bad foods from your
groceries
it makes so much more room for the stuff
your body really needs
you don't need those empty calories
you don't need those things
that are
gonna be adding
toxins to your body
and something i mean i have so many
people say well i get a good quality
olive oil
it's like no
no oil
take that
30 bucks for that good quality olive oil
and put it towards nutrition
yeah if you want good quality olive oil
what you want to do is grow an olive
tree and pull the olives off the tree
and eat the olives
and then you're only getting a tiny
little bit and i i love olives
but
you know what
a little bit of good
a lot of bad
that's right but eating those dollas was
not giving me what i needed
so
let's go for the whole
the big hammer as you put it
and give the body what it means
let's go to the next hand up
oh we're at the top of the hour do you
want to take a break or one more
question
uh let me do one last question we got
three minutes here or two minutes
all right
so treva
go ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with dr wallach
yes hi doctor
i apologize what's your first name again
triva
triva okay shriva okay yeah okay how can
we help you i've been taking your
products for a few months now but one
issue i didn't talk about because i had
so many others
is that i've had bloating
and gas
for quite some time now
and i finally went to a
gastroenterologist
and she um of course is gonna
put me on an antibiotic
very expensive antibiotic
and um
with no testing
it's first uh sibo s-i-b-o
no testing okay well let me quickly
intervene here um how old are you and
how much you weigh i'm 77 i weigh 108
pounds
okay
uh do you have any other issues i need
to know about do you have any diabetes
or hybrid pressure arthritis anything
like that
i i have some high high blood pressure
okay
i'm on a lot of your products
okay that's good
all right but the bloating and gas can
come from two or three different things
how much salt do you use
i upped my salt because i wasn't using
any
okay good yeah i want you to use our
pink himalayan salt
and there's cells in your stomach walls
called chief cells these chief cells
turn salt into stomach acid you want
stomach acid uh when you have a lot of
bloating that means you're drinking
carbonated drinks or your alkali
or you're alkalizing yourself by eating
lots of vegetables and everything and
not using enough salt not enough stomach
acid and so your ph in your stomach is
coming up towards neutral or even
alkaline and bacteria can grow in there
and ferment your food and that's where
the gas is coming from it's kind of like
making beer in your stomach yes okay
yeah and so you want more acid you want
to get your ph your stomach environment
down to two
you want to be extremely acid so it'll
eat through a steel
beam
okay
and
then it'll kill off all the bacteria
two things our pink himalayan salt is a
lot cheaper
than the pharmaceuticals are going to
give you and a lot safer because every
cell in your body needs sodium chloride
every cell in your body needs sodium
chloride for all these biochemical
reactions that your cells do when a
doctor says oh you know you're getting
up to that age cut back on salt or
eliminate salt because
uh you know it's gonna cause high blood
pressure and cause heart disease and all
that kind of stuff that doctor should
have his license taken away
salt
is one of the
most
required two nutrients
that all vertebrates require whether an
elephant or a human being okay so
after this morning i had
um
a full teaspoon
of pink himalayan salt on my wild rice
and my
soft boiled eggs
and uh this evening
i'll have
lamb chops
uh and sweet potatoes
and uh let's see here artichokes and
tomatoes and i'll use another
um
half a teaspoon or so of the pink
himalayan salt on those
all right
and so
that pink himalayan salt you'll never
have another belching burping bloating
bout if you use the pink himalayan salt
twice a day your food because it'll get
the ph of your stomach down kill off all
the bacteria and you won't have to you
know deal with all those pharmaceuticals
and all the side effects of them
okay
so that's
i tried to order it and it wasn't
it was out of stock
okay well when you
try again
and try again okay um and so you know
somebody who's involved and they may
have an extra a little
uh canister
and they can you know loan you one so
you can order two in yours and repay
them back or something
um but you know table salt
is just a white salt only has sodium
chloride in it which is not bad
but ours has 75 minerals in it
and then what about the iodine you're
not getting iodine with with himalayan
salt
oh yeah you are
are you
yeah
oh okay and you're and you're getting
iodine in the healthy brain and heart
pack also
well i'm not i'm taking the other one
oh
the other one the
the tablet the big yellow chair the
hanging
tangerine yeah okay yeah the tiny
tangerine has um has salt and and also
um iodine in it okay okay okay
all right
all right thank you
thank you chiva
yeah give us a call every couple weeks
yes and thank you everybody we are going
to take a quick five minute break here
on ask doc live so get up and
stretch and make sure that you have your
water cups full go ahead and put a
splash of minerals in that water so that
you're hydrating your body with
electrolytes because you know
electrolytes it's
minerals folks
you don't need five you need 60 so go
ahead and give your body some minerals
and some electrolytes and we will be
right back
um
all right everybody thank you so much
for hanging out with us on this a
wonderful friday for those of you who
are here live with us
we are so excited to have so many hands
up and so many questions coming in the
comments i'll get to those as as
in order that they were received
and for those of you who are joining us
on the replay
your questions are important as well if
somebody referred you to this program
make sure you get back to them it's
possible they have the answers to your
questions
if you were not referred by anybody
specific go ahead and go over to our
website ask
and click on the contact us
you can submit your question there
or request a free consultation
make sure that you also sign up to
receive our newsletter and
the notification that lets you know of
when our live shows are
so we want to make sure that you are
getting the information that you need
and deserve
but with our contact us we do have a few
certified holistic health coaches that
are there waiting to assist you and
making sure that you get the information
that you need to meet your health
goals
and also to
to cover those deficiencies that might
be making you sick
for those of you who have never spoken
to anybody ever before and you would
like to speak somebody on the phone we
do have a hotline
again this is for people that have never
ordered before
it's 855-949-7234
um so
we had this
cool little comment come through and
john writes doc wallach everyone is
doing great we eat like asians including
our jack russell
and he loves his supplements once
finished he carries his bowl around god
bless you dr wallach
so
always fun to have people share their
little testimonies of
of how they are doing and the
you know i i like to say
incredible and amazing
but it just makes sense when you give
your body what it needs
and since we are continually
regenerating cells and producing cells
there's no other option but for the body
to become healthier and stronger
and we realize those benefits
so
dr wellick if you want to go ahead and
unmute yourself
i think we're ready to get started again
and there we go
there we go
all right so i have another question
that came in
and
um it's coming from
abel let me see
and
abel
oh abel abel
and abel is asking how can celiac
disease be cured
i'm a 17 year old female
98 pounds
5 foot 2 inches tall
okay celiac disease is very easy to
reverse
like in two weeks
okay
celiac disease is a gluten issue
celiac disease diverticulitis irritable
bowel syndrome
um crohn's disease
all of those are all caused by gluten
um
things that are thought to be
autoimmune you know like um
psoriasis all those things are caused by
gluten they're nutritional deficiencies
okay so
at 98 pounds i wanted her to give up all
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meat you know teenagers that's all they
eat is you know french fries and fried
this and fried that and oatmeal for
breakfast and
colas and
when you look at it you stand back and
look at this holy moly how did they live
to be 17 years of age they should have
died earlier in that diet
okay and so um you got to get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no broth right no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go
use our rebound instead of colas for
energy has a hundred nutrients in it 75
minerals and 25 vitamins amino acids
then at 98 pounds we wanted to have one
healthy brain and heart pat per month
take a half a dose of everything twice a
day but with the exception of the
selenium i also wanted to get another
bottle of our slim so i can take three
of those twice a day
and then lastly i would like her to take
our msm you can take one bottle a month
in the msm take three twice a day that's
you can do it because it's a big bottle
and it will support and promote mains
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue including the walls of
the the colon
which is damaged when you have the
celiac disease okay
and um
arteries and veins and stuff like that
uh she's gonna be a new woman very
quickly and she does that but she's got
to be very very um which they say strict
with their friends and say look i can't
go with you anymore to these places
because they serve gluten
if you want me to hang out with you we
got to go to these places that don't
serve gluten or they have another room
that's gluten free and they have a whole
red they have a whole menu there's
gluten-free i can't keep going to those
places
like spaghetti factory and
mcdonald's and i can't go to those
places anymore because that's causing my
celiac disease okay
all right thank you so much dr wylie and
it's really interesting this week i
received a research paper from from my
doctor about your age
and
it and it was written about 10 15 years
ago
where they
noticed that after
and this was in the early 70s whenever
they really noticed it
after they did the genetic modification
on
the grains
in the early 70s they started seeing
digestive issues they had never seen
before
and now
they're they're things that
we um know as leaky gut
celiac disease
autoimmune conditions irritable bowel
syndrome irritable bowel syndrome and dr
wallach you've been preaching this for a
long time
yes
yeah it says
when you see
32 000 autopsies and you're looking at
their intestines and their colons and
stuff like that
uh it just makes you want to cry
because um just like we had the caller
earlier the guy had an appendicitis when
he was a kid okay that's that's due to
gluten appendicitis is caused by gluten
and i
i was affected by it i had my appendix
taken out in my early 20s
so it's
it's not fun it's very painful and if i
would know
would have known then what i know now
there's so much pain i could have
just prevented
over my entire life
so
but now
we can't change the past but we can take
this moment on share this information
with those that we know that we love
that we see that are hurting
and you can find the replays for our
programs at
askdoclive.com
or even on our youtube channel critical
health news you will find the replays
for this program as well
we encourage you
spread the information empower people to
be able to
have the knowledge they need
in order to
help
themselves dr wallick let's go to the
next hand that is up
and
robert
joining us again hopefully with a great
report robert go ahead and unmute
yourself
you are on live with dr wallach
okay
hello robert
hi um how did you see everybody let me
okay did you pay your light bill
you're good
go ahead
i look better you're fine go ahead sir
okay dr wallach you're wonderful and i i
enjoyed hearing the
other night on
oh it was with nori or somebody yeah
yeah george nori yeah well this is
george nori's program too but yeah
tuesday night
um
i'm on every five or six weeks
and um
george is the greatest
yeah well so are you you you you came
across wonderfully i appreciate it
but uh okay i i'm i'm in i'm in worry
mode now i went and had a blood test
and uh i think it's uh with that
prostate thing it's called psa number or
something isn't it
yeah well he he called up saying uh hey
you you used to be in the 20s now you're
your high 30s so you probably got cancer
and i'm going to okay
so
he started recommending all of this
putting me on the chopping block so i
want to see what what we could avoid all
that
okay well first of all i'd go to another
doctor for a second opinion
and you want to get a you want to get a
non-radiation screen okay a screening
write that down non-radiation screen
yeah screening yeah you know you want to
take a picture of your prostate gland
with no radiation no x-rays nothing like
that
okay
and so you want a non-radiation
screening uh but have a picture taken to
see if there is cancer you know it'll be
the size of a p it'll be the size of
walnut or something if you have cancer
there if they can't find any little
nodule of any kind the odds are it's not
cancer you can just have inflammation uh
in the in the prostate and the psa will
go up prostate specific antigen is
called okay okay why do they want to
start taking out a biopsy i guess that's
pieces of you right
that's right well they want to either
stick a needle in you or cut you open
and take a piece out but you can get the
same information
by doing one of these non-radiation
screens first okay
see he didn't tell me that
well of course not
he's got a kid in college and tuition is
due
okay okay you understand what's going on
here i sure do that's why i got your
book dead doctors don't mind
that's the only time they want lies when
they're dead
okay okay
so um so that's the kind of direction i
would go
uh do you have any other issues that are
still going
well i have that um
type uh two diabetic um thing uh i was
like the lady that called in she was low
on money so as i i haven't got the
things you told me to get for that yet
and i hope to
since i'm going to be ordering stuff for
this
psa thing whatever you tell me to get
i'm going to get all of that type 2
stuff at the same time
okay well once you get how much you
weigh robert i'm six feet um
192.
okay
um
optimally you want two healthy brain and
heart packs a month
obviously no bad stuff right no fried
foods no processed meats no oils or
glutens no wheat brown rhinos no sugar
no carbon and drinks
then 192 i want you to take two healthy
brain and heart pattern about the full
goals everything twice a day i want you
to take um
uh one bottle a month for msm so you can
take three of those twice a day
and then
i also want you for the diabetes to take
you have diabetes right
yeah thai too yeah yeah and so i want
you to get two bowels a month of our
sweeties you can take three of those
twice a day but don't cold turkey off
your medication
whether it's injectable insulin or
metformin orally or whatever
um but as your blood sugar begins to
come down you can slowly reduce your
medication based on the numbers all
right usually it takes about two to four
weeks you'll be off your medication
you'll be an ex diabetic
oh wow
it's very quick because type 2w is a
classic
nutritional deficiency just like scurvy
is a deficiency of vitamin c and rickets
is a deficiency of vitamin d
and then
diabetes is a deficiency of and i never
tell people what is the deficiency of
because then they run to the store and
they buy that one nutrient and then they
die
because they're 80 they're 89 short
right all right
so they die of a heart attack because
they didn't take the heart stuff
okay so that's that's why we came out
with a healthy brain and heart pack so
you take that and it's covering
it has 215 nutrients in the healthy
brain and heart pack and so it's
covering
um
about
over a hundred major diseases
all right including
diabetes but but if you have you know
diabetes it doesn't hurt to throw those
uh two bottles into your body wait two
dollars a month for the sweeties you can
take three twice a day but again don't
cold turkey off your medication based on
the numbers you slowly reduce it all
right okay
and then call us back
after you get the examination but i
would get another opinion i would not go
for a biopsy
okay we actually have products for the
prostate gland but i don't want to
suggest them to you until we find out
what's going on if you have cancer well
i'll tell you the one thing he did say i
don't know how he knew this but he said
that prostate was big or
swollen and okay well well that doesn't
mean anything
okay
that doesn't if you have a big muscle
because you're lifting weights does that
mean you have cancer in your muscle no
okay
now you have to appreciate now when you
when you have to get up at night to go
to the bathroom take a peek
yep
okay now that's because you have a low
back problem don't you
okay
okay the low back problem squeezes the
nerves to control your bladder
so the and the doctor wants to blame
this on your prostate because he has a
kid in college and tuition is due
okay
you got it
i always think they want to uh
make payments on their porsche or
something well something like that yeah
you got it you're thinking right okay
okay so yeah get another opinion and and
you want to get a scan
you know that's not radiation
okay
all right but i will
that msm will help you
deal with the back issue and after say
two to four weeks you won't be getting
up at night to use it the restroom
because once the pressure comes off
those nerves then
the bladder is happy let you sleep all
night all right
well thank you
okay give us a call all right
okay
okay i appreciate you guys nice seeing
you guys i'll i'll okay again
yeah please yeah yeah let us know what
they find
okay we'll do all right
thank you robert
okay
all right dr wallick we've got a lot of
questions um in the chat and one of them
is can i open all the capsules like the
ultimate selenium the glucogel the cell
shield and the sweeties and vitamin d
and mix with the tangy tangerine powder
and the osteoaffects powder
in water and drink it throughout the day
the answer is a three letter word yes
y-e-s
yes yeah we do that with kids that don't
want to take all those capsules and
stuff
okay so we we do that give them their
liquid of course we also have the kids
toddy for kids and so yeah no you can do
that
yeah and i love the fact that we can do
that dr welling because there are some
people that have a hard time swallowing
pills
and adding it to the liquid combination
of the beyond tangy tangerine and the
osteo effects
makes it just much easier and one thing
that i want to know
a note is a lot of people will say oh
it's just so sweet
well it's natural sweeteners
and if it's too sweet for you just add
more water folks
it's real simple
and drink it throughout the day you do
not have to drink it in a single setting
correct dr wally well that's correct a
lot of people you know within an hour if
they just shoot it all down
within an hour they have to go visit the
restroom you gotta go the ribs at the
restroom your tummy might start feeling
uncomfortable but if you drink it
throughout the day you're getting kind
of that time released effect and giving
your body nutrition
all throughout the day and not just
overloading it all at once so that's
correct yeah you don't want to spike
right you don't want a spike and and
and i have clients and i actually uh one
of the questions that came up in the
comments was in regards to
a client who would take the supplements
and then have diarrhea well spread them
out folks break up those doses
you know when you when you first start
supplementation your digestive system is
not ready for it
right because you've been on gluten you
it's gotta take you two to six weeks to
repair your intestines
right and and
i love the fact that we can just do
a smaller dose in the morning smaller
dose of lunch time
and get it into the body because if
you're not getting into the body
the nutrition that your body needs
you're not going to see the results so
keep going keep going
the next question is from patricia and i
see that her hand is up
and patricia go ahead and unmute
yourself
hi doctor hi patricia how can we help
you
um i have an 18 month old granddaughter
she's 29 pounds
and we're dealing with eczema
we thought maybe an egg allergy milk
whatever
but as i'm listening to your program
here i'm wondering about gluten
you get an a-plus
she's 18 months old is she eating
oatmeal for breakfast
yes well there you go yeah she's got a
gluten problem that's why she's got
eczema
because she's got a deficiency
it's not the
gluten that causes it directly but it
causes damage the intestines so you
cannot absorb nutrition
uh 29 pounds
um if she's not she needs to be using
the kids tidy and her efas the kids
toddy and our efas and within a couple
of days that eczema will go away
because she's headed towards at her age
if she's already got eczema she's headed
towards asthma does she ever have any
breathing issues or coughing or asthma
or anything like that
picture should go ahead and unmute
yourself again
she has not
okay good we'll catch it before she does
and so you know get her off all the bad
foods everybody in the household mom
dad brothers and sisters dog cat bird
fish everybody's got to be gluten free
so that she's not one to sneak it
because she'll see them eat it and she
wants to see what they eat
but she can have wild rice for breakfast
she can have baked sweet potatoes with
butter for breakfast
um and so forth
but she cannot have wheat brother rare
oats
okay
okay and it's totti or an
i find that
patricia if you
have somebody that referred you to this
program go ahead and get back with them
if you don't have anybody that referred
you to this program you can find those
products at askdoclive.com
in our store
okay thank you
you're very welcome and then give us a
call in a couple of weeks and let us
know how the granddaughter's doing
okay thank you doctor okay patricia god
bless
all right next let's go to christine who
has her hand up
christine
go ahead and know good morning
you're live with dr wallick can you hear
me yes ma'am
hi thank you so much for for everything
uh
you have uh shown me and taught me i
heard you on george nori many many years
ago
what really fascinated me dr wallach is
that 90-day
eye experiment where there was um a
bunch of people that took
specific uh supplements so
um what happened is uh one was legally
blind and they were able to
drive again
and so what has happened now
with me is i forgot certain of the
supplements and unfortunately my reading
glasses have now become my seeing
glasses so i don't know if i became used
to it
or
since i was wearing them all the time or
okay
how old are you christine 46
and what do you weigh
uh 125
and i'm 5'2
okay do you have any other issue do you
have any ring in your ears or balance
problems or hiccups or anything like
that yeah i do have um tinnitus in my
left and then i do also have
my l5 s1 so that's my lower back
issues for six years as well as two
small bulging discs in my neck plantar
fasciitis
mild abdominal aortic plaque and
so pretty much inflammation
okay did you have your panics out when
you were a kid
no but just a year ago i had some
abdominal pain and urgent care sent me
to er to rule out um acute appendicitis
which i went and got a ct scan and they
said nothing's wrong with you and
my report was just mild um abdominal
aortic plaque but that wasn't a
diagnosis he sent me home so i said
can you at least prescribe me something
for gas i mean i spent eight hours here
at the er
okay
all right we have osteoporosis of the
skull tinnitus is a squeezing of the
auditory branch of the 8th training or
by the skull when you have this gradual
vision loss it's called ona optic nerve
atrophy
and
your skull is squeezing the optic nerve
the optic artery the optic vein
i actually had a wager with the eye
doctor in salt lake city utah
yeah and he gave me 27
of his patients
and he had diagnosed as being legally
blind six eight ten twelve years so he
couldn't argue about picking the
patients because he's the one who picked
them make a long story short within 90
days they can all read 2020 without
glasses
because i put them on the program i'm
going to suggest for you here okay yes
all right so here we go 125 pounds once
you get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens a wheat bread ryan notice no
sugar no carb in your drinks either the
diet one's got to go
i want you to take um
see one healthy brain heart pad per
month get another bottle of water sleep
so you take three selenium twice a day
because there's a bottle of slime comes
with that healthy brand hard pack wait
three selenium twice a day that's
correct but you're gonna have to get
another bottle of our selenium along
with the one healthy brain and heart
pack there's one bottle of slim in that
pack
but it takes two bowels to get three
twice a day okay and you want me on the
healthy brain and heart that's one a
month
yeah 125 pounds is correct
okay
now i also want you to get our
um msm i want you to get one bottle a
month for msm so you can take three of
those
twice a day okay you'll be able to do
that because they're big bottles
and that'll support promote mainstream
pair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between vertebrae
bone makes including the skull
okay that's going to help you with the
optic nerve atrophy and the squeezing of
the eighth cranial nerve
okay and
also it's going to help you with the
disc degenerative disc disease the low
back issues
and all the stuff that goes along with
that any numbness and tingling in your
feet and toes
yep okay that'll all go away
um i do want you to take some collagen
okay
i do have yours i love it thank you okay
you're talking about the liquid or the
capsules i have the powder
oh okay so you have the uh the um
let's see here peptide right the quality
collagen peptides okay good yeah so you
can take a couple of scoops of that
twice a day yeah
okay good
and then call us every couple of weeks
because you're going to have a great
story uh the ona optic nerve atrophy
goes away very quickly the ringing the
ears can go away in two to four weeks
and your skull will regrow and your
teeth will tighten up did you have to
wear braces when you were a kid
yes went to an orthodontist yeah that's
because you'd obviously process as a kid
of your skull
and your facial bones your jawbone so
your teeth were moving around because
your skull wasn't hard enough to keep
them in place
and so that's why you had to go to an
orthodontist when you were a kid
okay
okay so give us a call and you're going
to have a great great testimony thank
you so much uh dr wallach one more thing
um yeah
now should i also incorporate the
fucoidal z
and um
uh glucogel
well kill the glucogel is another form
of collagen okay um you can take we have
capsules you can take your body weight
you could take three twice a day or you
could take the liquid in quartz uh you
could get one quart and have a half
ounce twice a day of our liquid
collagen
okay you can do that glucogel
and the fucoid z we have two forms they
have the capsules you could take three
twice a day it's two bottles a month you
prefer the liquid it's called z radical
kids little kids like it because it
tastes good
you could take a half ounce of that
twice a day
that'd be one quart a month to the z
radical if you choose that form and the
the fucoid z and the z radical are made
from
seaweed and all the weird trace minerals
of seaweed and of course not only does
your bone love that but also your bone
marrow which makes
white blood cells and platelets and red
blood cells and antibodies and stuff
like that help you
with your immune system in this time
pandemic yep
yeah it won't hurt to add those on but
what you're saying is the collagen the
msn and the healthy brain with the
selenium with those recommendations of
the quantity and frequency of it should
already help uh do or per the experiment
that you did do with the other
optomologist
yes
okay good and then what about um i have
the pro joba should i be incorporating
the omega-3 at all to help me with all
this
okay well the omega-3s will be there'll
be some omega-3s in the healthy branded
heart pack but if you want to get an
extra bottle of it so you can take
um
you see you'll get um three you get a
bottle of the efas and if you get about
the f8 pluses take three
twice a day of each
right
okay
all right thank you thank you god bless
you all thank you okay thank you
christine
awesome christine great great question
yeah that was that was a wonderful study
that god's just got to go back 25 years
where i got those 27 people all 27 of
them could read in in less than 90 days
they were totally blind six eight 10 12
years the doctor couldn't
argue with the patients who were picked
because he picked them right
and he lost a bet so he had to pay for
all their supplements
and he
and he had to buy me a nice big bottle
of red wine from france and take me out
to a steak dinner at ruth christmas
steakhouse
and then he did a bad thing he decided
he was gonna go with a bunch of bad guys
and people always say what was his name
i want to talk to him well i don't refer
people to him
anymore because he was a bunch of bad
guys and claiming he was the one that
figured it all out
and so um we don't talk about that guy
by name
yeah
we've got to give credit where credit is
to you folks
well dr wellick i have another question
here that says what can
one take who has endometriosis and a
herm or her
it's a
hemorrhoid hygienic
cyst
age is
okay so wait wait a minute you got a
hemorrhoid cyst and endometriosis and
endometriosis
yep
um 135 pounds at five foot one inch
okay
so i wanted her to stay away from all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens a
wheat broth ryan noticed our sugar no
carbohydrate drinks
and then
135 pounds again
she needs to be on one healthy brain and
heart pack per month get another bottle
of water selenium so you can take three
twice a day she needs one bottle of msm
so you can take three of those twice a
day and that's for the walls of the
arteries and the veins and that kind of
stuff
and also for the um
uh connective tissue
uh um
in the uterus
okay
and
the muscles in the uterus and then also
i want her to have
the um let's see here
sarah femme zero fem x-e-r-a-f-e-m
you should get to two miles a month of
that so you can take three twice a day
or two three times a day for a total of
six a day
and that's going to
help her
with her cycles that's going to help her
repair her uterus
it has all the nutrition in it that the
ovaries like
and make
more estrogen
more
progesterone and actually help repair
the uterus okay
all right thank you so much
again everybody if you are liking what
you hear get back with the person that
shared this program with you
or if nobody shared the program with you
go to askdoclive.com
we do have our store there we also have
a contact us that will allow you to get
in contact with a certified holistic
health coach that can assist you in
making sure you're getting exactly what
you need based on dr wallach's
recommendations
dr wallach let's go to the next hand
that is up and
is it
yorkie
your wonky go ahead and unmute yourself
hey how are you i'm uh i'm gary
gary all right gary hi you're on live
with dr wallach hey hey doc i i listen
to you on coast to coast man every time
you get on there i listen to you one one
one a.m in the morning 2 a.m in the
morning you must be on the east coast
you must not sleep yeah
um uh just quickly i
i
injured my ankle at the end of august
and i was i thought i just
twisted it so i kept walking on it
and
walking on it and standing and standing
and working
and i ended up with a deep vein
thrombosis diagnosis
okay
now
i listened to one of your podcasts and
you recommended the healthy body brain
and health pack and the essential fatty
acids plus and the ultra niacin plus
because i'm because according to the
gentleman that had the deep vein
thrombosis you said he was most likely
low in omega-3 fatty acids
um i also have developed because i'm not
walking correctly i'm on blood thinners
by the way they found out um that the
blood i ended up with the blood clot
um and they put me on blood thinners as
soon as they found out how long ago was
that
about three weeks three weeks ago
okay
now
and how long have you been on our
products
well i'm gonna start i'm just gonna
start them
okay so after you go a month on our
products then you want to
um as you know go back into the doctor
for tests and see if you can cut the
blood thinners in half or something like
that
uh within 90 days you should be able to
get off the blood thinners
right they're going to give me another
test the doppler test at the end of
december to see if the blood clot
resolved itself okay
one other question i developed sciatic
extreme sciatic pain because i'm not
walking correctly because i'm limping a
little bit because of my because my leg
is swollen okay okay how much how much
do you weigh 180 six foot
do you have any diabetes or high blood
pressure
no diabetes high blood pressure
you did have a little bit of cholesterol
okay all right well here we go none of
the bad stuff no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bread rhinos no sugar no
carbonated drinks i want you to have two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
two healthy abandoned heart packs a
month
and i want you to take a full
three of the efas twice a day and three
of the efa pluses twice a day right
right and so that's all in those two
healthy brand hard packs
then
um i want you to
um get two bottles a month of our
msm this is going to deal with the
sciatica and the bone and joint and disc
and all that kind of stuff tendons and
ligaments and so once you get two bowels
a month over msm's you take three with
breakfast three with a lunch tree at
dinner time and they're going to support
and promote mainstream pair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between the vertebrae bone makes your
bone cell
and
then for the high blood pressure
i want you to have our ultimate daily
plastic tablets you could take two
bottles of that a month take three twice
a day don't cold turkey off your blood
pressure medication
but as you know test yourself two or
three times a day
and as your blood pressure begins to
come down you can slowly reduce your
medication for high blood pressure based
on the numbers and usually within
60 to 90 days you'll be totally off the
high blood pressure medication
all right but you still have to stay on
all of your nutrients you still have to
stay off all the bad foods how long do
you need oxygen gary
noah forever
oh oh you mean yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i get it okay right how long do you
need water
yeah every day how long do you need the
90 essential nutrients everybody knows
all the time yeah and so you're lucky
you're getting some you know you're
getting some early warning signals here
by having some
relatively low
threatening things like a blood clot in
your ankle
all right um
and so that tells you that things are
going on
see how old are you what's your age 63.
do you have any gray hair
yeah well can't you tell look
oh well would you look at that
you could go for santa claus all right
um
yeah absolutely and i just started to uh
at that past five years i started knee
these uh cvs glasses
mm-hmm okay i wasn't wearing any glasses
up until then
yeah well the odds are you have
osteoporosis instead of squeezing the
optic nerves you have on a optic nerve
atrophy so that'll all go away
okay
and you're going to get your hair color
coming back the hair color will come
back in your beard your mustache your
hair
and you're going to look 25 to 50 years
younger and people are saying are you
dying your hair you're looking so young
wow so i won't look like santa claus
anymore no
all right
well thank you for the for the advice i
i'm so thrilled that have talked to you
and i thank you for the program and
um
uh rebecca who i get an email that's how
i got this so who recommended me do i
look on my email a recipient
reply to your email
that's a great question
okay
thank you
look you're
forward to hearing from you all right
thank you so much god bless
all right thank you thank you gary right
right not what your students think says
all right i'll look for your email
well
all right dr wellick let's go ahead and
go to the next question and it's coming
from monica she wants to know and this
is general question of how to get rid of
shingles in an older man
well i don't know that that's the
shingles she's thinking of
so let's go with the one that has this
um
you know
herpes zoster i think yeah yeah yeah
exactly
okay
all right
um basically this guy needs to get rid
of all the bad foods right and then
let's go by a hundred pounds of body
weight if he weighs 150 pounds freedom
is 200 pounds but per 100 pounds of body
weight i want him to have one healthy
brain and heart pack per month
one healthy uh excuse me one
bottle of msm per month for 100 pounds
of body weight
vitamin d3 three of those twice a day
for 100 pounds of body weight
then i also
want him to have
our
hair skin and nails
three of those twice a day
per hundred pounds of body weight two
bottles a month and then
he needs to be taking our colloidal
silver because it kills viruses
including herpes and so forth right
so
um need to take uh two droppers full
hundreds tongue 30 minutes for each meal
30 minutes for bedtime so we'll need two
of those four ounce bottles to do this
for a month this won't hurt to be taking
this now because of the pandemic going
on also because it kills viruses don't
forget the hand sanitizer um
and
there's no alcohol in it so it doesn't
burn so no matter where the herpes
lesions are this hand sanitizer can be
applied even in sensitive areas it won't
hurt
so
uh you can apply the hand sanitizer
directly to the herpes lesions like
maybe
three or four times a day
and then you know give us a call every
couple of weeks and give us a testimony
because
the herpes lesions will go away
all right thank you so much dr wallach
and let's go
to our next hand that is up and it is
mark
mark go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with dr wallach
i think i'm unmuted now is that right
that's correct you're on oh okay um
uh dr wallach i have a
swelling on the back of my head that's
intermittent
there's like a raised area
um kind of at the base of my skull
um okay have you been to a chiropractor
no i've not i'd go to somebody like that
a non-invasive person i'd go to a
chiropractor and have them examine you
and see if there's
something going on there it could be a
disc
okay swelling it could be just
connective tissue it could be a um
it wouldn't be a fatty thing because it
would stay up if it comes and goes
it you know it could be something going
on
again with maybe a joint capsule or
something like that so i'd have a
chiropractor look at it give you some
kind of sense of what's going on there
um
and
how old you and how much you weigh
i'm 64 and i weigh 190. do you have any
other issues how about pressure diabetes
arthritis
uh no my doctor thinks i'm pre-diabetic
but he's not
i don't know if he's very uh capable but
you know
um well he takes your insurance money
doesn't he
um well yeah they all accept money
that's a that's a pack so okay yeah so
anyway um any rate
uh so at 190 pounds
again i'd go to a chiropractor and have
him examine your neck and all that kind
of stuff and see what's going on there
but i would take two healthy abandoned
heart packs for a month none of the bad
stuff no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens uh how tall are you
um five foot eight
okay
so 190 pounds that's about right
um
at any
rate i want to
uh have you again
uh take two healthy branded hard packs
for a month to full roast everything
twice a day we also like you to have two
bottles a month of our msm so you can
take three with each meal and that's
gonna support and promote maintenance
repair of um cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae bone breaks bone itself also
because of the pre-diabetes i'd have you
get two bowels a month of our sweeties
you can take three of those twice a day
and they'll you know very quickly get
that blood sugar under control and you
can you know you can go to
a
pharmacist without a prescription and
get the test strips and the little
things that stick your finger for a drop
of blood or you can get the test strips
you can pee on and
see if you have sugar in your urine all
that uh it costs you 25 cents each you
know
um it's not like they're expensive and
it saves you from having to go to the
doctor and pay a lot of money and sit in
the waiting room and get the covered
virus with everybody in the waiting room
coughing on okay
yeah um
speaking of the copa virus i guess
that's a good lead in also besides the
swelling i've had
once or twice pimples form on the top of
my skull
which i believe were associated with uh
i have taken the vaccine
is that one of the side effects are you
aware of that
no
not in particular but
when you have anything like eczema or
pimples in your scalp and stuff like
that it's due to a particular deficiency
and any kind of inflammation can
aggravate those things and make them pop
up
and so a lot of times
when you get
those skin issues it could be it could
be i'm not saying it is it could be
related to
the
vaccination because the way vaccinations
work is they cause an inflammation
okay they do cause inflammation and the
the inflammation is to awake your body
to the dna
and rna of the bad guys whether it's a
virus or bacteria or fungus or yeast
and so a lot of these sort of
um reactions really are happening to
people because they're nutritionally
deficient if they had all their
nutrients
i mean i'm i'm 83 years old
when i had my
two vaccinations i didn't have any
reactions at all
um
of course i've been taking the 90 cents
of nutrients for
75 years and been gluten-free for 75
years and when i was in the military
i'd get 10 vaccinations at the same time
once a year you know if you're in the
military you know that they give you
every vaccination they can think of
ones you've never heard of because
you're going to a certain place and they
want to give you those vaccinations plus
they gave me rabies vaccination because
i was a veterinarian at the time
and so
and so um but i never had any never had
any reaction to all those 10
vaccinations at the same time because
i'm taking my 90 essential nutrients and
avoiding gluten
yeah i'm i'm trying to avoid the gluten
it's hard but there's a lot of it out
there
well well you have to you have to find
places that serve food that doesn't have
food in it and frequent those places you
just can't walk in any place and try and
get gluten-free food but there's
gluten-free ice cream which i have a
third of a pint of gluten-free ice cream
every night for dessert along with my
glass of red wine no gluten in red wine
and
to go out to eat i go to you know
someplace like
a steakhouse
and they do have
isolated rooms
uh and say you know just tell the
waitress look we're gluten free don't
bring us any bread don't bring us any of
that kind of stuff
tell the cook we don't want anything on
the grill oh we have a separate grill
for gluten-free okay well good that's
what we want
but don't bring us any bread or
pretzel sticks or anything like that
okay
because uh
we are gluten-free and so you just have
to go to places that will you know
follow your instructions and so forth
you have to know to tell them on the
front end
that you're gluten free so that they
know to be
um aware
aware of it and to react appropriately
okay
okay thank you very much
you bet
awesome thank you very much dr weilach
and oh we have so many we have hands up
still we have so many questions in the
comments if we do not get to your
question
please go to ask doc live
and
use that
contact us option with your question and
we will get answers for you
next let's go to don who has
his hand up don
go ahead and unmute yourself
let me get
you are on live with dr wallach
let's try again i can't hear you yet
so i sent you there you go you're on
live
i'm uh six foot 220 pounds 75 years old
i've uh i'm on your products i've been
buying them from victor
until he passed away and now i buy them
from maria
i've got a chronic sinus condition that
never seems to go away
and um
my feet hurt really bad and i've been
getting um
b vitamin injections between my toes and
around my ankles it seems to be helping
in the black veins are disappearing
but my feet still hurt
okay
all right gsa is eight
okay just for you know your
our other listeners at 220 pounds and we
need to get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens a wheat bread around no no
sugar no carbonated drinks you know the
diet one's got to go use our rebounds
for strength for
uh energy and a pleasant uh something to
drink
for nutrients as well as energy
then i want you to have two healthy
brain and heart packs or months and you
may be doing some of this but our
listeners have to hear the answer too so
two healthy brain heart pattern month to
full dose everything twice a day then i
want you to get two bowels a month of
our msm saying take three at breakfast
three at lunch with dinner time and
that's gonna support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
a vertebrae bone makes your bone cell
all right and
then
i also
want you to
it's also going to help with the skull
and which may
involve this chronic sinusitis thing you
have then um once you use the colloidal
silver two droppers full under your
tongue three minutes for each meal and
two drivers full on your tongue three
minutes for bedtime these are hand
sanitizer between your toes there's no
alcohol in it won't burn
and then also
i would throw in the killer biotic which
has the reishi mushrooms in it that
supports the immune system and also
anti-inflammatory it relieves in
discomfort and pain
and so see here
then i would also
um
take our
let's see here
collagen peptides
okay i want you also to take the
collagen peptides you can take two or
three scoops of that in the middle of
the day
uh that's going to help rebuild the
discs and the bones and the cartilage
and bone matrix and stuff like that for
your feet and your back and so on
and then i also want you to get our
collagen gluco gel
you can get the capsules you can take
five of those twice a day i do that and
i only weigh 142 pounds i take five of
the capsules twice a day
especially when i'm on the road
sometimes on the weekends i will use the
liquid collagen and take an ounce twice
a day of the liquid collagen but i
always take my collagen peptides in the
middle of the day two or three scoops i
usually put it in some applesauce or
something like that
or sometimes you can mix it with your
liquids and it goes with the liquids
very well
do those things and then call us every
couple of weeks because you're going to
have a great story
you know your
um
your story with the chronic sinuses
can tell you that there's something
going on with your skull do you have any
ringing in the ears or balance or issues
or
no i had vertigo one time and uh i i
thought that was probably from the
bluetooth hearing aids and i put those
in a bag and haven't used them since
okay and haven't had a problem since no
okay good all right
let's go with that program and give us a
call every couple of weeks and we will
appreciate that because
there's a lot of people out there with
your list of problems including the
chronic sinusitis and they will be happy
to hear your testimony okay
thank you very good thank you so much
all right thank you don
let's go to and just a little quick note
um dr wallach i used to have sinus
infections four or five times a year
and since being on the products i have
not had a single sinus infection i love
it isn't that amazing
i love it
let's next go to our last hand we've got
four more minutes we've got margaret and
go ahead and unmute yourself my dear you
you are alive with dr wallach
thank you hi dr wallach um my family and
i we appreciate you so much and um
we're meticulously gluten-free
we're still healing um
certain things but we're on a whole
spectrum of youngevity products
being very careful i would like to i
love i love goat milk goat cheese goat
butter i would love to go back to eating
those but i stopped because i was
concerned because i know that they eat
gluten grains
um
am i making an error and being concerned
about that
okay what you want to do
is um start out with just just either
the milk or the cheese
you know for one meal a week
okay and see how it goes
because the gluten doesn't come through
the milk okay
okay
and so um and goat's milk is very good
and remember that most of the people who
are were apostles
okay
and teachers of the word whether it was
the old testament of the new testament
were
uh
herdsmen
they had goats and sheep
and so you're in good company when
you're drinking goat's milk and eating
goat's cheese and so forth okay
thank you
okay that's right that's a that's a
great question
that absolutely is a great question and
you know
oh
i pushed the wrong button
dr wallach we are at the top of the hour
again i can't believe how quickly
these two hours go by and on behalf of
myself and our crew here at app stock
live we just want to thank you
and and
oh just appreciate you so much well
thank you i'm the one to appreciate you
guys you're the team you're the family
and i cannot thank you enough for all
that you do thank you so much for you
and your team
well thank you and yeah i'm gonna say
thank you to all of our
subscribers
and everybody who is on live with us
today because if it wasn't for you this
information would go nowhere
so feel free to share
um as we had a one of our callers call
in and want to know well i got this
information because of the newsletter
who do i call
reply to that newsletter and we have a
team of certified holistic health
coaches that are answering those emails
as well
so everybody
god bless
we will be back
next week same place same time
share this information
um because it is empowering
and
i i just can't say enough so i'll just
shut up
live.com
askdoclive.com
have a great one and bye for now